بحسابات اقتصاديه وجيوس سياسيه فان رابطه
دول جنوب شرق اسيا احتلت اهميه جعلتها
هدفا يسعى كل فريق اما لكسبه الى صفه او
ابقائه على الحياد على الاقل مجموعه اسيا
هي الايام منظمه اقتصاديه تضم 10 دول تقع
في جنوب شرق اسيا وهي اندونيسيا ماليزيا
الفلبين سنغافوره تايلاند بروناي وفيتنام
و لاووس وميانمار وكامبوديا في العام 2020
وفقا للبنك الدولي بلغ الناتج المحل
الاقتصادي الاجمالي لدول اسيان ثلاثه
مليونات دولار ما يجعلها ثالث اكبر اقتصاد
في اسيا وخامس اكبر اقتصاد في العالم بعد
الولايات المتحده والصين واليابان
والمانيا ويبلغ عدد سكان الدول الاعضاء في
هذه الرابطه الصيام نحو 700 مليون نسمه
اين يعادل تحاول تقريبا ثمانيه فاصل
ثمانيه بالمئه من موعي سكاني العالم لكن
سوق اسيان تضاعف ليشمل مليارين و300 مليون
شخص وثلث نشاطي الاقتصادي في العالم مع
توقيع اتفاق الشراكه الاقتصاديه بين
الرابطه ودولي المحيطين الهندي والهادي
وانضمام الصين وكذلك الهند